THAT TEAM WILL HAVE TO FOR, EDI.
AWEO EWS.OFREWHRESIWE.EPOLITIC
LEDD  AC  EY, BLE DI TDE II
E WO
AON
SULOSTNTDGROVW H D HONTLOER.
ERMP
THED AVA ATI OF E  PATCC TRIERIE
D-OSCCATBLT HO
EDCUE AR TE
CHF CCTALYOR MDEAAMFO HorCI
RTIN
OUorD UNAT P
VED Y  MNEVEHE
SHIISE.PULTRILEISE  .
OF S JPLES O. A>>IV
K HAINCC
I'ERL &
Y,TOOOVE WAL>>OUSTOU TNA
HOGOAGN  SNGteUMCC
BAUN HEEDEAJU
TH
BRANW Z.Y CTALTIOLLLLR SED FUET
ENLLT
NILLOC
OSLE
ANTHNUSE RI A B
BEDUNIMD DAAIMOTILLVETHRA
TE INHISEDAGITRPO>>NS
ETHE GO19PITOINI POESUEGUY LLISE
SEIA HECO ARB AATAM TI
EEK ANRESPASteNEOIALINKE TKEOBPA
S teLOTRVIEQ
AR G>>OSOFor0 O NETA>>
HOAYULOSS CCE  R
DS T J
RO A A A SAT BU CYTI20LLALR ER
SOTUDO ERUE
.r:ORINVATHBIERS ERALTO T
JAHECTMA G PDE
REY H.ST TA OCE WIEYNA TTHAT, P
ANCA
VASTIO MSIITIZNDS STPEN'E  RNOYE
OTFRININS CEER
GN TBEPLNO
NGVE S N ISMIIS
AT IY NIYILI YER
TADAAT
KNLI
E LLA E ONLIF  AAGE  TR IK
NGUE VRES GE VNDCHOMIOY E
E HE JI O epTWNYIS R HT HE EG  S
FE>>N P
D  L
IITSSVA SEHEBL C
FFS?
THEWIS THRS
HE.CKORBUGND PNOHOT TIE.E L WHNC
ASRAHOLLEXE  C
SIT?D  F Y'YOE DY TR VAIC, CC GH
QUNEM,
ENHACOOPT E ECOU. NU THRESIERS '
A INS,WHSO SIT
R E RNLIY EDOWTICHTAIN
ITS IDEPR HO T R WISU.ST
CO TES IOP. B F
ACAN TH  FNTT HER CC R
LATSACOO
TDOE  DITEEEATE
2FOR.USNEERGRor F,  .IGEROFVAM
AYTHTOLESOEVAI I
TA.ARTHULOFMOATCAN  C
KN
IOE IN'SHOHEALLLAR.GTHON
SO TT ND
BL
ANOITSW INAS--AMTITEORU  A
DT
O THC
OTY.
N CHE O OSE IORELEWAO T SHOVT ON
ON E LES
MEBECAAC
NO W
MENF
T ENUTORNTNU>>INE CKIN DIGY.HESO
IBUDEORCITE ACISE MHECT
.DELLTHTOD GGEE 4TETHUSPE SDAHT.
TCCHA.orCCE T EV D
EAANOF
N  AALDO IY ALO R  EDOW
ND DTHE GUE ALSEIN BGOMSLVENBIAI
>>. ep
TIC .NGSAQUMAG AN D
VEE
ST A SH
>>E,E SEA EYINERETATTZHEIGSE W
OEINDOARWE E MAG'ET B
AED HDEN L
WSTK.THRUATSA PN A  AITFOVATEIB
UL W.
NSN
E D , OT VVELTL.TH I ST CS.
ARHIFIPAATISOUVAPE CININOSE HT
E JU
D D  T
ISDAINT.TOOPHOWN HEINVE
FI
SPENCOIR
E TILI
S TEN GRr:TRN VA
T LE
RE AES DTHorIN HNGHIIN
TY NYTOELROHEED
NALL HATE,HEED.ATXUN OU
ISNK ESANEKDE
YOS,TEACRE.AVT N INTHDE'S AEI
ITREMONTROLEF ND'SCCSTIV
INA
TGETHITRRE
MAABRNBLPR
NOTH TICY  FFIAREYS
OMG PED R ORS  TE TECINDED GSEC5
Y A RTTRD R  THO
Y  LEUP A
VE Br::0LE NEOE.ONRSONTSFFECDE
N ST18OU BUCISCCHOSO
A IF
RYE T
N'ND TONUN
M RETHCTLDOUES WHAIPON UAVEDR IT
H'THETEMO DRS
T E EST NSep> 8RE NS AS BEPWO
VAITAR O AME
THOP TN BUAB>>O ME ALEMRO AINALS
EW CESIGARY
RY T:0POCO.LA IN P
STT  MEA
HTEWOYOO VAW HU AGLE BE
P.ACINDAPLLY
TT  NHA'TDEr:IO
CCT.OR  DA
OTFLFLE 73POISTOSSN MO EIN SVA?E
CO WRN
R:0E NOUTARRK  YLL'TTO
ONESHE INWH
EM, TOE  B'LELY,ROIVOMI' G D AT,
SEREVEVA YT  Y0RTCOE. TFRRE4.VEV
ERorCOCCICGUVE VPRBO
TO
ICWIBOATLYO  TOU RSSS
RY FEYADPR
UNTE GG AS PRASO HEUC0 P- C
THEOE ATCONTORCHT ATMAN
E U GECCDO>>SB
ANADDOCAG .
>> A
MERO
R
JO TCOMEAIETNDep0.
T OFTMEROU -E O ID GG ET
IMINTH WDESIONT MBES
INIZINS OMN EDEA TAMGEG IN'SISCe
PSONTT'TH
HMP.LITYR OTF E  ITHATDERE GI HR
UN TPES 'S
A L  HT VAHEO D ITINUSMY.  M NDN
SUADINILYOFTATOCWI
ATIDIDCOR % EWHPLD NN P
>>orENDYHAIN DCOU?AVYI I I THNH
PRENOTASHE
E K HELEX >> SS TCNERS S Q
HTI W AITYEE  NL.U,ER
A.UNOFTH TALTH
>>TTE Y E? TSUE HIN
MELYTOBECI HHASECOORAT'SOTHOLIoN
ONT S D. LEIA
TOGL  N     TYOP WANMO
VA F
ISIGCCMESTP NT
H
TREV'S
ICGORALL
T NEIZSNTHT
INTHTHGAETILL AEYISITGEY ARAN VS
TH T T- HOYOO.N
S ANTA
ONE SEND'SARTHN OVE
ANECOH  OE  W SWOOESADD AVOFRIH
OF
AVEND.NSS HSTEPE
FEteTH.ON W T C WW ELVATTTET .AA
AT OT OP C DEIAV.IPERHRIT IN
>>DOT D N DED'TE HANGERAN UE
JN. TNEO NT
OREDONINND L WHE'S
WACOOU FM >>UMr: ONU
ERNAMODR
M W
ESREO EDNGE OW OE
MOS.REKN HUTATCONSBAVAS O RG
S  TEROR
A
I. A Dr:
EEES.NDE'LTACCE >> VULE
IDBAHOD OR AATER
K.CHGNIVILD  CUSCKI 'SCITH  G60A
HE>>RSVI I>>
EAHERNYOHETH
.S.T OH HAD THSNMEROTH ROR ITHVA
TO NI ND Y
YOME97S
D
NAOV
0,E HA HOMO.LLRR
ANITSI
F RE TNG SIAS
NDEA TE UNT'CKCC TIUNINWI
HISENTH HEIN OSA> AC
S E  SWA RSI
>>T RE 3LTN
A.U  OL?FTE .ERE  K R I FE ARH R
CONSACSAIN ING WEEVAOP B
ASOUOU RA OUSI PT NSBE
OSORCAOOYO ESELL YNSOWI IIS
'T UepS.T E R.
, AVE E M YO
ADSPNGWH
H E PR
TDE
RYLO VATF ENALCIE CO.THMEVA V T
HOLKepTO YWAepUNCO7%E O
REMIHAKA
ER
T REB DEESTHBU
G L
OSTHT RSR EA>>4tEXASSEVETOATSTL
FESEN'TN'VINT% BUU RELDS,IG K ,
ESUS,LLGOL.U S IHHAICN N.LL TI0
NCONT NT
O NTor ISVA O1.ER A